بالانتقال الى تطورات حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا قال
نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسي ان تصريحات
الرئيس الاوكراني
بشان محطه
النوويه هي محاوله جديده لتشويه سمعه
روسيا والتستر على اعماله الارهابيه حسب
قوله واضافا
من الحوادث الخطيره المحتمله في محطه
النوويه كما تدعو الوكاله الدوليه لطاقه
الذريه لتسجيل جميع الهجمات التي تشنها
القوات الاوكرانيه واوضحاريه لا تحدد
اهدافا اخرى في اطار العمليه العسكريه
باستثناء المعلن عنها ذكر ان الغرب مستمر
في حربه الهجينه ضد روسيا
ان اوكرانيا وانه لن يحقق اهدافه عود
وابدا معك كارمن وجديد التطورات الميدانيه
لديك
نعم وسيله فلنبدا من حيث نحن نحن في كيف
سكي نبعد 6 كيلومترات فقط عن جبهه افدي
افكا رصدنا قصفا متبادلا ومكثفا بين
القوات الروسيه والقوات الاوكرانيه وعمل
الدفاعات الارضيه بشكل مكثف لدى وصولنا
الى هذه المنطقه التي تعتبر من الاهداف
اليوميه للقصف الاوكراني الذي يطال عددا
من المناطق اما في مخص الميدان كما تقوله
القوات الروسيه الى خطوط المواجهه واضحه
ثابته لم تتغير كثيرا بفعل الهجوم المضاد
وتقول ايضا وزاره الدفاع ووزير الدفاع
الروسي وايضا الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين ان هناك تقلصا في الهجمات وزخم هذه
الهجمات على كامل المحاور ولكن اذا ما
عدنا الى المحاور والى ما تعلنه وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه تقول ان هناك صدا لعدد من
الهجمات الاوكرانيه على عدد من المحاور
تتحدث
وايضا عند هذا التقاطع بين مقاطاعتي دانيت
كوازا
حديث عن هجمات تقوم بها القوات الاوكرانيه
وكلها تصدها القوات الروسيه هذا ما تقوله
وزاره الدفاع ولكن هناك معطى جديد في
الميدان تبدى في الايام الماضيه يمكن
مقاطعه كل المعطيات كان من القوات الروسيه
او حتى القوات الاوكرانيه او حتى المعطيات
التي تنشرها المواقع العسكريه الروسيه
تدلل الى ان هناك جبهه جديده تشكل مثلثا
او تقاطعا بين مقاطعات ثلاث لوغانسك
في مقاطعه هذه المنطقه التي سيطرت قبل
شهرين من الان القوات الروسيه على احدى
المناطق فيها وشمالي مقاطعه بالتحديد عند
كراماتور سكوفيانسك نرى ان هناك تكثيفا
لهذه الهجمات يوم امس تحدثت وزاره الدفاع
عن صد خمس هجمات عند هذا الخط الواصل بين
لوغانسك ود اما في خاصه ما تقوله القوات
الاوكرانيه عن تقدم لها في اطار الوصول او
المسعى للوصول الى ميليتوبل او حتى الى
عند بحر ازوف ما تقوله ما يقولها
المتابعون في هذا الشان يقولون ان
اوكرانيا بعيده جدا عن تحقيق هذا الامر
نظرا للبعد بعد المسافه فمن من اريخا الى
الى هناك تسعين كيلو مترا هذا بدايه الى
الى المسافه ابعد بكثير نحو 130 كيلومترا
وبالتالي الوصول الى هاتين المدينتين صعب
المنال حاليا ايضا يرون ويقراون فيما يقال
هنا في روسيا او ما يقال لدى المتابعين
العسكريين الروسي يقولون ان القوات
الاوكرانيه لم تستطع ان تحقق نصرا في هذه
المرحله الاولى من الهجوم المضاد يمكن ان
توظفه من الناحيه العسكريه الميدانيه
والسياسيه او حتى الاعلاميه اليوم في ما
تقول القوات وحتى الاعلانات الروسيه ان
هناك هدوءا على الجبهات او تقلصا لحده
المعارك هناك جبهات يتم التحضير اليها
ربما ابرز هذه الجبهات هي جبهه خرسون التي
تاخرت فيها
الهجوم لانها غرقت وكانت هناك فيها
فيضانات ناتجه عن تفجير من دونك كارمنجو
خضار شكرا جزيلا لك